[Music]
as you may or may not know the super
bowl took place a couple weeks ago and
um this is the first one that i've
missed the first super bowl since i was
a toddler probably since like 1980 it
was because i was driving a van
across the country and i had stopped in
a in an rv park in the bay it was really
beautiful god was a cool
sound of frogs and spanish moss
everywhere and i felt like i don't need
to see this super bowl i was i've had
some things to think about and you said
to buy you right yeah okay what did you
think i said i figured you did but you
you didn't really enunciate it you said
buy it by
like but like the bayou biopic
i was walking taking a walk around the
rv park and it was beautiful the sun had
just set and was
dusk you know you know that's my
favorite time of day
i looked in one of the windows of the rv
at this like a fancy rv i had a little
van of course no tv in there but there's
a big fancy like winnebago and i looked
in the window and they were playing the
game
i found myself watching it for a couple
seconds and like trying to see the score
it was the first quarter so it wasn't
like that big of a deal but i was then i
started getting a little curious about
the game
i thought how funny and potentially
scary it might be if somebody
turned around and caught me he's a
peeping tom
you're a peeping sports fan yes yeah
i was life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my um
similarly uh football
loving brother christian that's fair to
say we were just talking about how much
we miss it it's sunday today
and uh yeah it's yeah i miss it but we
shouldn't there's only nine more months
no less than that you saw the whole game
it's march now so we have you know six
more months uh yeah that's real the
season starts oh boy i can't wait yeah i
facetimed you that night um and you were
showing me a little bit of the game uh
but it was a not a very good guy i was
relieved to learn it wasn't a good game
it was not a surprisingly
not a very good game tom brady did it
again well i'll tell you the super bowl
that was a good game a couple years ago
the bet i think probably the best super
bowl biggest comeback in super bowl
history i
had seen the first three quarters of
that game it was the patriots and the
falcons
and i was doing a play in san diego and
my my friend donald and i were really
faizon former guest uh real friend of
the show friend of the show we uh we
were really into the show we were really
into this the game and we had been
watching it at a bar and we were like oh
it's a bummer we gotta like
you know miss the super bowl because we
had a sunday night performance because
to do a play tattoo to tread the boards
because the people who were coming then
we thought well maybe they'll cancel the
the play how are they gonna have a play
on someone who's gonna watch he's gonna
play over tom brady in the super well
i'll tell you who
people who go to see plays at the old
globe theater on sunday night
yeah and these people were you know they
just were
much more
much more into theater um and so we're
doing we're backstage listening to the
game and we were so relieved because by
the third quarter we felt like okay it's
a blowout we can
we can go do the play we don't have to
think about the game and we're not
missing out on anything uh the falcons
are way ahead
it turns out
how many points how many touchdowns were
they had in the third going into the f i
think they're done
fourth but going at half time they were
down like four touchdowns it was a
blowout it was a mask but then going to
the fourth quarter i think i think it
was even i think it's still like a four
touchdown lead which is if you follow
football that's like
insurmountable
it's like um
so it was a relief to us and then
at intermission we went backstage again
and uh somebody was like i i hate to
tell you this but
they're coming back and it's an amazing
game and we were so pissed to miss it
but uh it was a good play happy we did
it and i hope people enjoyed it no
regrets wow you know if people people
didn't know any better and they just
heard of like a handful of random
episodes of this show yeah they might
think
that it's a tom brady themed podcast yes
that's how often we mention him uh have
we mentioned him on every episode surely
everyone but it's like you know that
seinfeld thing where he's superman
superman is mentioned speaking of tom
brady a lot yeah like in many many many
episodes yes um anyway why are we
talking about we're not really talking
about tom brady i i uh pivoted to him
because it's so hard not to know it's
the elephant it's the gorgeous elephant
in the room of course but what we really
are talking about is uh this recent game
you're talking about the falcons losing
to the patriots and why are we talking
about the falcons well i'm glad you
asked our guest today
as you may know
it plays a character called the falcon
on uh i almost said on on the television
and that but but anytime sometimes and
coming up on the television um our guest
today is the wonderful actor a friend of
mine a great guy one of one of my
favorites anthony mackie
anthony is uh known i think best
audiences as as the marvel character the
falcon but in the mc's
yeah which i this is i can't believe i'm
asking this but mcu stands for marvel is
it cinematic universe i think so okay
you don't know
i think i never thought about it but i
think it is you hear mcu all the time i
uh crush money remember that yeah i've
never been certain what it stands for i
haven't seen it i think it's cinematic
man crush monday in a while do people is
that woman crush wednesday i
thankfully i don't follow people who do
a lot you know what's really silly is
sometimes i'll find myself like i'll
find like an old picture from something
that i want to post it's like a tbt but
it's not thursday so i feel like i can't
post it it's not crazy
so i'll be like well i gotta wait a
couple days and then you have something
to look forward to two days from now i
get to post that fun picture picture
uh anyway anthony mackey if you are not
familiar with the mcu like clearly we're
not all that familiar with it uh even
though i like a lot of those yeah
avengers iron man you haven't seen as
much as you should you should know i
know i should they're i know they're
great movies great actors captain
america yeah well good yeah you know
that he's in it i know who's in the
universe you were so proud of yourself
hulk
yeah
the hulk that's a tough one for me to
say the hulk uh you may know him from
other movies like hurt locker hurt
locker that was a big one and um he's
done great theater too from uh amazing
stage actor yes i've seen him juilliard
grad he's uh
oh here's what you'll not have better
credentials yeah you'll probably know
him from uh his work in
tenure the reunion the college that's
oscar isaac and all these guys that at
the time were um just about to break
they were about to they're on the cusp
of stardom but they um we it was about a
10-year for the few of you who don't
know it uh channing tatum produced it uh
and it was about a
high school reunion it's just a reunion
movie most of which was improvised and
that's where you met him yeah yes did i
i feel like i knew him before that i
hadn't met him before but um that's
where we got to know each other and
really got to hang out because the whole
thing we shot in albuquerque albuquerque
kirk kirker uh in this hotel shout out
to the andalus my favorite hotels in
albuquerque yeah boy is that a that's
funny why can't i say that albuquerque
in albuquerque it's hard to say fast but
uh we we shot most of it in this hotel
and
you know again it was improvised and it
was uh it was just so fun and easy and
we were right there in the hotel and so
we did a lot of we got to hang out a lot
uh the whole cast got to know each other
well so before we get into this we
should
um
say we should we should say that
while you're listening to it around
around the halfway point maybe maybe a
little sooner i think like the quarter
mark oh really yeah he so when i when i
first zoomed with him which is how we've
been doing them for the past year almost
an entire year uh he was at a bar he was
like outside i was in new orleans and i
was so jealous i just wanted to jump
through the zoom and be there because uh
great area but um it was a little bit at
first i thought oh this is going to be
unusable because it's it sounded so
chaotic where he was he was you know
saying hi to people and people were
passing them by buying you'll hear
you'll hear you'll hear but um it ended
up i think it sounds really fun and then
so then
at a certain point his computer died
and in the middle of a sentence yeah it
was a good story too yeah and then the
next day they
pick up the interview this time he's
home
and uh full computer and it feels like
it was seamless because our brilliant
editor mish was able to stitch it
together in such a nice way that uh i
don't think it's uh it's gonna be too
upsetting for the listeners but just to
give you a little heads up that that is
what happened yeah and we talk about it
too in the thing but like yeah it's uh
here we go yeah let's hear it so
speaking of that that um here it is uh
my my ketchup with my old friend the
great actor anthony mackie
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
wait where are you you would like this
place they have they have one dollar
beers okay
okay but
it's not they have one dollar beer i'm
cheap i like beer i know that's what i'm
saying uh you you remember me well yeah
uh
wait anthony where this is great so
you're in new orleans yeah i just got
just made it back to new orleans what's
it like there now buddy what how is the
what's the vibe there it's all good it's
uh what up joey it's warm it's nice
people lifting it up
who who is was that somebody that you
knew from before i can't tell if it's
my boy dre
now ironically enough he just got pulled
over by the police and he got out of the
car and walked to the bar and got a
drink and is walking back to the police
to get his ticket
[Laughter]
he's like if you're gonna pull me over
i'm gonna make this time worth a little
while i'm gonna go get a cartel and i'm
gonna sit here and wait for you to give
me my ticket they're a dollar you can't
put that down no matter what your
predicament
you grew up there how far away from
where you are now did you grow up um
maybe
two miles i mean it's a small city so i
grew up in a part of town called
gentilly which is north of downtown so
right now i'm downtown about a bridge uh
by the front on the other side of the
french quarter from the house okay and
is that the area you're in now is it
touristy is are there a lot of people
who
might be like uh
marvel fans there yeah this is the
touristy
area that's where everybody come and
walk around and get their drinks and
their
hand grenades
and eat their
muffins
all right man you say
and now who was that
that was the people that was sitting at
the table you know you say hello and you
say goodbye you say goodbye steve as a
new yorker you guys don't get it's nice
to be courteous so you say hello to
people and then you say goodbye yeah i
do that i'm very courteous
i miss new orleans so much is that
was it just that in terms of living
there anthony do you just you prefer it
to the vibes in new york or l.a no for
me you know i wanted to
have my family here because you know i
lived in new york
and uh i just wanted to raise my kids in
an area where there's culture and
history where you can actually know your
neighbors where you can sit on a couch
and like a band comes up and plays music
i was like you can't find that that's
true what about you don't have kids dude
i have no kids no no i mean
you're afraid of kids what happened i
love kids uh i kind of you're a fruitful
successful man i know i i i don't mean
to say i know i didn't mean to agree
with that successful part uh i'm
fruitful
i don't know man i it's a long story i
think i missed the one that i should
have done it with i
right i missed i the one there was one
that got away um and then the other ones
were um that'll do it yeah that'll do it
that'll do it i'm sort of relieved you
have four
i have four boys oh my god
i got lucky so i figured out the way how
to make boys so all of my friends they
came to me and was like yo you know can
you like what'd you do to get your voice
so i told them if they gave me five g's
i would give them the secret so to to
date my technique has been tried and
proven 12 times so eight of my friends
have had boys wow oh whoa we're getting
this this is a scoop
yeah yeah yeah what is it i can't i'm
absolutely not going to tell you because
you're not going to give me 5g
wait is it really a technique like like
a physical physiological thing it was a
technique scientifically proven
works 100 of the time where did you get
it from how where did you learn it i did
my research i was like yo you know
because i was the older man when i had
my kid i was 30 years old so i was like
you know at 30 like you know what do you
do do you drink this do you like to wear
ice underwear like what do you do so
hold on wait wait wait before you say
that anything why did you why were you
so dead stunned on having boys women are
very mean to me like it's in their
nature to be mean
so
i was like
i've been tortured my entire life by
between my sisters my aunts my friends
like why would i bring a little girl
into the world to torture me for the
rest of my life okay okay that's like a
self-help hatred that i would never
understand uh-huh yeah you wanted a
break yeah i needed a break i needed
boys
and because i know if i had a little
girl like i'd be [ __ ]
putting barrettes in her hair and going
shopping every day
i would be that dad i would be like the
best daughter dad on earth and i
couldn't i couldn't do that to myself
that sounds so nice no i know dude and
listen i'm imagining women listening to
that and swooning hearing that
[Laughter]
i'm spooning a little bit yeah no i mean
get an easy bake oven like i would i
would love i would adore my little girl
yeah that would be the problem okay all
right that would be the problem okay i
couldn't do that to myself so you wanted
a little you wanted some guys some some
fellow
guys you can kind of horse around with
yeah my little and that's that's who my
boys are we literally
like fight around the house and shoot
nerf guns at each other and that's i
mean that's my house is a disaster
24 hours hence why you're at a at a bar
right now
what how how what are the age ranges
what are they eleven eight five and four
like my four my four-year-old is a pre-k
three drop out like we're doing this
like zoom school [ __ ] uh-huh so he goes
he signs on for like 30 seconds if he's
like i'm out i'm out but it just walks
up do they enforce what do they do yeah
i've always wondered that how do they
enforce it right
right it's really weird so you have to
sign on and they like tell you what to
do and how to do it and you know the
weirdest thing is like doing pe because
the kids are like it's just weird and
nothing about it makes sense and do you
have to be there do you have to be
supervising it for the most part yeah
you don't have to be but i try to be
because
like
so much stuff can go wrong yeah you know
and you know kids man you tell them to
sign on and they're like signed on
yeah you know so you have to smack them
on the back of their head to make sure
that they're uh they're paying attention
and they're all in different classes
eleven eight five and four
they gotta all be in different classes
so are they in different areas of the
house how does that work nah they're all
in one room and they're 11 year old and
the eight-year-old go to a french
immersion school so they're only taught
in french so i have no idea what's going
on anyway
just because it's a great school i
wanted my kids to learn another language
i really wanted them to learn spanish
but uh
we didn't have a good enough school to
teach spanish so we got a little um the
french immersion school was the best
farm language school
um and it's a public school oh wow it
just worked out yeah yeah we anthony
when you said so you said you were 30
and you were like which i can't believe
you described it as being old to have
kids i'm like what the hell am i then
i guess i guess the ship has sailed for
me
i guess i could still be a grandfather
um
what uh what so you were like i want
boys
i'm dying to know what it was i know
you're not going to tell me but but
how did you what research did you do to
figure out how to only have boys
it's just it's a certain it's not a
position it's not anything like that
okay it's not any of that [ __ ] it's
literally you know at 30 years old a man
testosterone kind of drops is just his
spermies like get sleepier so you know
the older you get the sleepier they get
i've heard that yeah yeah you have to
invigorate yeah how did you no
was it a dietary thing just give me the
general
yeah 100 100
the force
of manhood wow
wow the the last thing i'll ask about it
i'm not not asking what it is but how
did you
did your friends actually pay you did
did they did you collect all
all of them cashed up for me five g yeah
yeah
all eight of them no [ __ ] all of them
all of them paid me yo were there any
that were like oh dude you were serious
about
you really want me to pay well yeah and
then i made them payment i was like you
give me a hundred dollars a week or you
can you're gonna pay you're gonna pay
was here i gave you my technique you
used my technique your wife said you
used my technique because she was
like
my friend their wives would call me and
be like why did you tell him to do that
to me oh okay that's a hint it's
something that is to be done
to the lady
and were they appreciative were they
like i wanted a girl i'm sure some of
those women wanted girls
no all of them wanted oh everybody wants
a boy
but now everybody wants a boy but but
then okay i get after like i get the
first maybe the second
even the third but after the third
weren't you like oh it'd be nice to
switch it up
no absolutely not
absolutely not i always said from the
time i was a teenager i always said i
wanted four books wow
always one
you can ask my college girlfriend she'll
say we would date and i said i wanted
four oh my god
wow
girls are mean people man they're very
mean
are you sure it's not girls your sister
no girls are so mean dude they're so
mean they're mean to each other they're
just me
well i've heard
well this is i've heard that that boys
in the beginning are tougher like the
first couple of years
they're they're they're a handful but
then they they become easier whereas
girls in the beginning are easier right
that's that's very true but my boys you
know my boys are great they're
respectful boys they have a great mom
they're very family oriented so they're
just respectful little boys but i look
at my friends with girls and when they
hit
12
yo
god
all my boys are they're just being
tortured by their doors
how many sisters did you have
i have three sisters
rough yeah sisters of russ yeah i read
the chekhov clay
were you where were you in the ages
where in the uh i'm the youngest oh okay
yeah everybody's older than me but
because of that i was bullied when i
left home and when i got home like
bullying was my upbringing okay did is
are any of them performance incline
where any when you decided to become an
actor was that like out of left field or
or is that kind of in your family are
they're all professionals but they're
all comedians in their own right like
you know
no time at our house growing up was
boring or dawn there was always
something going on so they still give
you a hard time when you when you when
you're all together my sisters yes yes
what would they say about this like you
you complaining about them on this if
they listen to this not that they will
but if they do what would they say about
it what would their reaction
do an impression of their reaction
i couldn't even imagine it would be they
wouldn't even say anything it would just
smack me on the back of the head that's
their go-to move
just really matter what just straight up
what are you saying
that's
uh
my older sister would say oh big movie
start doing a zoom
oh really
did your dad did your mom and dad give
them a lot of authority like to kind of
discourse yeah hell yeah yeah yeah you
asked my my sisters well i had like five
moms
and literally but to that same end
like if they if i'm out of town they'll
come by and clean my house like they'll
drop off dinner for me like they take
care of me like i'm like one of their
kids so it's their mothers in a good and
bad way
one hundred percent one like
if you come to new orleans they'll take
care of you like you're my friend that
came over from school oh that's cool
that's cool they're hilarious
yeah
your dad had a roofing company right he
was a roofer yeah yeah he did
construction construction
was that something that he did you ever
think about when you were a kid was that
ever talked about you going into since
it was a family business oh we all did i
mean every summer the boys had to every
summer the boys had to go and work with
my dad from like when the summer you
turned 14 you had to take the summer and
work three months on the route wow and
from that everybody was like nope going
to college never getting on the roof
again and that was it it was
the worst experience you could ever
there's no nothing like working on a
roof in new orleans
i heard it's tough i mean regardless
it's a really hot you're working with
this like hot sticky isn't it it's
grueling
yeah tar is like
650 degrees you're mopping it with a
real mop good in 100 degree heat with 95
like the fact that my dad did it for 40
some odd years wow it put everything
into perspective
wow did he have very um he must have had
very worn hands his hands must have been
really calloused
definitely a very hard hat yes
that's why when he said something
everybody listened because he could
he laid the gauntlet of what dad's role
was in the house so everybody
was deathly afraid
of you know my dad came home everybody
be quiet he ate his dinner go take a
shower that when the house wakes up but
you had to be quiet while you eat wow
wow yeah it was it was like
it was hilarious but at the same time it
was
you know i had the best
uh
parent duo i could have asked for yeah
yeah and and probably instilled in you a
real strong work ethic i mean you
just of course yeah
yeah of course of course i mean because
when you see it it's one thing like i
would drive by and i would see him on a
roof or i would go when i'm gonna buy
materials but once you do it yeah and
and to think that he did that six days a
week
that well that's
like yeah man i wouldn't i don't know if
i was mad enough to be able to do that
yeah it's funny i know you did a lot of
theater um
when you started out you were doing a
lot of probably odd jobs and stuff and a
lot of actors will complain about that
like oh i paid my dues i did
i did see and it's like it's it's still
fun it's still not it's not roofing it's
not roofing
you're in the air conditions yeah
yeah
um how different is it there now after
katrina anthony what was the what was
the biggest change that you've noticed
post katrina new orleans you know it's
very different because a lot of the
locals left and so many there's been an
influx of new yorkers and people from
california moving to new orleans so it's
been a drastic change in the culture you
know it's uh
new orleans is 100 a city that's made by
the people who are here
and a
huge i would say like a third of those
people never came back wow
and they were you know replaced and
because of that
you know the neighborhood demographics
have changed drastically
the
culture of the city has changed like
it's it's become this hodgepodge of what
it used to be where it used to be a
cultural mecca now it's a whole lot of
people that move here and say oh you
know i'm from new orleans
like stop talking like
yeah like i lived in new york for 12
years i would never say i was from new
york yeah you would never adopt like
some like no no no and then i wouldn't
come to new york and try to change it
like i wouldn't come to new york and be
like yo we need we need a second line on
the weekends in new york no that's not
new york culture
you know so you know are there it's
weird yeah well are there still those
pockets i mean and if so where are they
this where it doesn't feel like it's
changed it feels still kind of untouched
like the new orleans that you grew up
with
well you have the bowl so the bowl
uptown is gone uptown is just a
disgusting mess of gentrification yeah
and then you have gentilly which is
starting to change which is where i'm
from yeah but once you go to the
outskirts once you go across the river
once you go to the east
like
the surrounding area yeah they're still
very warm but once you're in the bowl of
new world is
it's like a random awful
like housewives of new orleans it's so
annoying
just 105 pound women in
five door suvs trying to kill it
yeah i know i've noticed it's it's uh
but it's that but then around the other
corner it's like the coolest bar you've
ever seen and right the best sandwich
spot yeah i mean like right that's the
new orleans that i really miss and um
is it
how has it changed for you because i
know it's a very visible place there are
a lot of people um it's a great place to
people watch obviously but since
your career has changed and
what was the turning point where it
became
people spotting you people coming up to
strangers coming up to you since hurt
locker has gotten more obviously because
of the marvel uh thing yeah but now you
know i have my bars here my restaurants
here where
i'm
isolated more insulated yeah they make
people leave me alone so i have my
places where they look out for me and
they treat me like a regular person yeah
which is all anybody wants yeah you know
what what did you envision uh being an
actor would be like what did you want
you know i thought when i got out of
school i thought it was going to be more
about me
like doing like regional theater and
doing independent movies and you know
working at the guthrie and mark taper
and you know alabama shakespeare working
all these regional places and doing
these plays and every now and then
getting a small role or doing something
in the film yeah that goes along like i
thought i would have more than free
career where at 55 i would do a role and
people would say who is this guy why we
never see them oscars yeah everything
for you
like i thought that then before then i
would do like the magic school bus and
play yeah you know yeah i thought i
would have that i never thought it would
um
be as steady as it has been
so
so uh
and i've been very fortunate to be able
to do all the projects that are
different and fun and creative and work
with all the people i've wanted to work
and do you miss doing theater anthony is
that something that you want to you
would love to do again
i do i do i i was supposed to do a play
this year but you know kobe took care of
that right so now what i'm looking at
doing because i don't have anything
lined up because
i'm looking at getting a group of
friends together here in new orleans and
putting on a play oh that's cool and you
would do it outside or something like in
a no no no no no we have a beautiful
theater here downtown so we're like a
six it's like a 750 theater right
downtown new orleans uh friend of mine
owns it he renovated it to the nines
it's all beautiful so i want to do
something like in new york uh philip
seymour hoffman has a labyrinth theater
company oh yeah i did a yeah yeah i used
to do their summer program exactly so i
want to do something like the labyrinth
put in the wall and put on like
spongebob the musical or something
exactly you do a community-based theater
program where you have regular people
and actors coming together
to
to do a show and you know you have the
kids uh programs along with that so they
kind of work in cohesion oh that'd be
cool is that in the works are you are
you working on it now
yeah yeah that's what we're working on
now that's
that's that's that's our that's what
we've been working on the past month is
just picking the play and getting the
people together that you know would be
able to be a part of it and do it oh
that's cool yeah yeah do your kids show
any aptitude for that stuff
oh yeah tough
and uh because both my two older sons
are in drama class at school are they
little they're little hams
yeah oh dude and they're they're pretty
good eight euros pretty good wow
like last year they did uh my 11 year
old his class did uh hidden figures they
did a drama versus stage play of hidden
figures in 11 years i am
yeah he played kevin costner
[Laughter]
you know it was the funniest
he came in like with his little tie on
and he had a little a little like name
tag that said boss and he's like what's
going on here
no more
no more colored restrooms
that's a really good kevin costner
impression
oh i would have loved to video man
i'm pretty amazing what do they think of
your uh do they get excited by the they
must get excited about the superhero
stuff
not at all oh my kids are my my kids are
really into me being tagged like
whenever
you know you get to a point when you
have kids you start doing [ __ ] to try
and impress your kids like you know i'll
do spongebob part five my kids watch
spongebob you know yeah and then you
know your career goes in the tank
because you're doing all these awful kid
movies
well that happened to me even without
the kids
i just wanted to impress random kids
right
um
what what do they think of so what do
they think of the superheroes though i
mean are they they must be are they into
the marvel world at all
they're they are a little bit uh you
know it's different because they're more
into like that video game minecraft
oh yeah there's this new game called
roblox i don't know what it is but they
play it all day
and it's it's rope it's not robot it's
like roblox or something like that
but that's their thing there's not so
much movies and [ __ ]
you know they know you as dad so it must
be like well yeah i don't want to see
him wear this suit and like pretend to
save the world
i tell them all the time i'm like you
know like
that's their whole thing and they have
no interest like we'll go to the
premiere and i'm like yo everybody's
here to see your dad
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
who were those people for you grown up
like if you would have lost your mind if
you saw blah blah blah like i i'll have
to say clint eastwood
wow in in the black household you have
bruce lee clint eastwood and everybody
else not kidding they have honorary like
entrance into black
clinton is considered the baddest white
dude of all time i'm like wow i didn't
know that did you and you got to work
with him did you tell him that right i
did
what did he say to him
i was like you know like the old black
dudes you're the coolest white dude to
ever live
he goes i've heard that before
[Laughter]
that's pretty that's a pretty cool
response
now because if you think about it like
dirty harry oh yeah obviously the man
would know the the the man with no name
series all of that [ __ ] like and the
same thing with bruce lee like there's
an interesting connection between
african-american culture and uh
like kung fu karate culture like when i
first moved to new york i used to live
in harlem and you would walk down 125th
street and they would have like bruce
lee movies playing on the sidewalk
outside of stores and just a group of
black dudes standing around watching
bruce lee movies like when jim kelly
when jim kelly became the black dude in
the bruce lee movies that was a huge
monumental moment like as far as film
and as far as black
like people the xiaomi and all that i
mean all that [ __ ] is just there's a
marriage between the two cultures that a
lot of people don't talk about or
identify but it's really interesting was
it jim you said jim kelly or not jim
brown no no jim kelly he was the
amazing
uh black kung fu dude who was in all the
bruce lee
and and and they started doing a lot of
those moves in the black exploitation
movies then exactly exactly so that's
how that crossover came about and you
know it was you know like
everybody knew who bruce lee was yeah
that's why you have so many young black
dudes today who like to read and they're
so interested in learning about bruce
lee you know because he was such a
monumental figure in our culture for my
parents generation and so that was that
was a guy you looked up to but but but
was it like i want to be
in like a movie star like that or i just
think he's cool and i want to be an
actor i mean do you remember the first
time you you fell in love with it you
set your mind to wanting to do that
so i was in second grade
and we did a puppet play called walton
matilda and i got the lead role right so
i did my puppet and you know he's
welcome matilda and i'm doing my little
puppet [ __ ] and i got a standing ovation
in second grade from seven years old
from the puppets and i was like i can do
this i'm balling i'm gonna be an actor i
understand innovation from all four
shows a two-day run i crushed it
wow
what and did you uh we've been talking
about this a lot on the show this keeps
coming up for some reason i i have a
real aversion to um
curious how you feel about this up to
bowing i i got a note once the the a
play i did a couple years ago the
director was like justin you gotta
uh you gotta you gotta like spend more
time bowing i i i wan i went down and i
i got really self-conscious about it i
hated it i hate it and there was an
actor on here who was like i [ __ ]
love it it's not for you it's for the
audience how are you with stuff like
that you know what it's the bowing is
the only time that like my ego kicks in
and i'm like yes yes come on yes you
love me look at you look at you look at
you yes
your worship before me
but anthony i think that's more common i
i think that's um
and i think that's more honest my
brother was saying the same thing he was
like i love it i love when
you just did this thing and like people
are showing appreciation
[ __ ]
well what's weird is i feel like we
spend it's the funny thing like with the
marvel stuff we spend so much time like
putting our energy and focus into
projects to present them to the world to
be critiqued and as an actor people
aren't saying oh i don't like the
character you're playing they're saying
i don't like you yeah so it's a very
personal critique it's a very personal
dislike because you put so much of your
person into it right so
like with the marvel stuff it's the only
experience i've ever had where no matter
what you do you know people are gonna
love it so it's almost like the
gratification of all gratifications you
know and it's the same thing when you're
doing theater like
the theater going audience is so polite
that even if they hate it they're like
you said all your lines you're very good
you said all your lies yeah
you did you didn't [ __ ] your pants you
didn't
yeah
not that i know of anywhere that i know
i mean you hell you hated well yeah so
you know it's one of those things where
you just you got you get to
feel that gratitude and appreciation
just for you showing up
there's nothing else saying in your life
that's true
and it's infectious like you can feel i
remember one of my first broadway plays
was this amazing play called uh bringing
the noise bringing the [ __ ] we're saying
and it literally
i mean it gave me goosebumps like it
felt every time
it was the show because he went away for
a while because he had like a uh i think
he went into rehab or something then he
came back
and
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay wait i'm gonna try to tell him
where he's
[ __ ]
okay i just want to set up for
the audience that you are now in a
radically different location
totally different demeanor anthony is
your home it looks like a nice couch
nice living room area where are you what
am i looking at i miss the people going
by looks like a nice couch a warm uh-huh
yes yes
nice nice earth tones hues
i'm all about earth tones man i'm all
about earth though yeah people know that
about you that's a well-known thing
um
so you were what if i'd just been here
the whole time like yeah you were saying
savion glover use this yeah
uh
thanks for doing this man you must be
slammed you sound busy i apologize my
whole thing just crashed the other day
and the it was a ridiculous situation
but we're back we're back okay and we're
uh we're almost done we but you were in
the middle of a really good story about
sabian glover he had left because he was
not able to bring into noise or defunct
um as i've been working on that joke for
24 hours
uh and and he had to go away for some
personal reasons what so what happened
during that time and uh how was that
instrumental so i was just getting out
of uh julia george wolfe
who recently directed mahrez black
bottom uh with viola davis and chadwick
he directed this show
and
i worked with him on the off-broadway
production of top dog underdog with
jeffrey wright
and don cheadle i had seen
this show and jeffrey wright was the
voice he was the the catalyst for the
show he was the narrator yeah watching
this show and the performance was so
infectious and savion was like
on another level like if you play sports
there's a term where they say you're in
the zone and this dude was dancing to a
point to where i felt like his soul
was being left on the stage and
it really blew my mind the way theater
could affect people like the way i was
affected the way people were even when
we did top dog underdog there were
certain nights where jeffrey wright
would perform and people in the audience
were so caught up in the performance
that they would call out to him as the
character in the show what during the
show they were so during this wow wow
wow he had this whole politically where
he was doing three carmani
and you know he was doing it to himself
just in the room on the spotlight this
amazing direction by george c wolfe and
you know under the spotlight he goes
do you see it and every night someone
was like i don't know which one yeah
they were so yes yeah they were so into
it they were so hypnotized by it yeah
wow when i was in college you know we
would get all these tickets to broadway
shows and i never missed a show and i
saw maybe 125 broadway shows in my four
years ago oh my god
of all the people you know
james earl jones patti lupone like bb
new worth uh uh you know b arthur all
these amazing and some of them
dreadfully awful some of them absolutely
amazing like i remember 19 years old i
love my girlfriend so much i slept
outside the theater for a day and a half
to get tickets to line standing room
tickets to lion king people would sleep
outside the theater i slept outside
theater from friday after class until
sunday morning oh my god that was that
was that hotter ticket i guess so the
julie tamer one right
yeah when it first opened it was
i saw lion king the first month it was
open wow because i stayed
for a day and a half for standing room
ticket oh my god wow what did you see b
uh you say br three you saw her in
something yeah b arthur did a one woman
show and i was so in love with golden
girls growing up i was like yo be
arthur's doing the show i gotta see this
show yeah yeah who who was your you know
we used to ask anthony on the show which
golden girl do you identify with we
stopped asking because not enough people
were that familiar with the the golden
girls but who who would yours have been
i love sophia if i could have my my pick
of the little rose would be like my
little boo-boo
well fortunately for you she's
what she's still just happy right yeah
99 years old still kick him
they're so good i go back and watch him
sometimes and that the time they they
hold up in a way that's like no question
no question i watch them every night on
lifetime yeah
8pm 12 midnight they run
like eight episodes of golden girls i've
seen every single one uh and speaking of
plays i i had to ask you about be
handing and spoke you say spokane or
spokane
okay
spokane um i saw you in that you're
incredible everybody was in that play um
and i remember seeing you afterwards and
and
something happened with watkin like he
had
i had a brief interaction with him then
and you kind of i remember having a we
exchanged like a funny we had a funny
moment just because he it was it
constantly that because i know sam got
really close to him um but were you able
ever able to like break through with
that guy no humans
are equally as weird so they like
they're perfect together i remember the
funniest [ __ ] of all time and
no one has ever heard this story if you
interview matt damon and he say this
story is not true he's a [ __ ] liar
okay so
we're doing behind and that's in spokane
and matt damon is like yo
you're doing a show with chris walken
you got to bring him to my house
i'm invite a bunch of people to my house
i'll send you a car you gotta get chris
walken in the car and bring him to my
place i think it was the championship
game or it was a big fight it was some
big sporting event i was like all right
i'll figure it out right so i'm talking
to chris all through the show
so
through this show the raps and i'm like
yo chris man you want you know my man
matt's having a little get together at
his spot
you uh you want to go
and he's like yeah i'll go i'll go i'm
not doing anything i was like i bet what
do you drink
he's like
telling my drink opus one
what's that
is this red wine blend from napa it's
like five hundred dollars a bottle
right
so
matt
go like oh [ __ ] chris walker someone
coming to my place i don't have any opus
one he runs down the block to the liquor
store you know remember the liquor store
used to be on a block uh down the block
from the public
but yeah
yes on lafayette on uh yes yes
yes so he runs because matt used to live
over there he runs into the liquor store
he's like i need a case of open swamp
they're like cool that's 3 500
he's like
he writes a check right oh my god
and the dude is like i need your id
so matt at this time you know i think he
had a born movie or something coming out
so he looks at the entertainment weekly
and he's on the cover of the
entertainment weekly amazing and he's
like here's your [ __ ] id and he
takes the case
that's amazing
wait did so did walking do it just to
see test
whoever was throwing the party did they
know each other
no they didn't know each other wow
so
he grabs the case of opus one
who you just know three thousand dollars
in liquor he's like is chris coming i'll
go pay him tomorrow it's fine
so
and
it was oh man it was it was a night of
all nights it was hilarious what was
what is he like in that atmosphere i
mean no if you have red wine he's there
chilling
all night amazing
is the funniest we had a great time
doing that show man like between
you know the three of us and uh zoe it
was
it was amazing like there was everybody
was
so cool and i think sam was kind of like
the barometer of that like it's hard to
be an [ __ ] when sam's in a room he
waters down everything that yeah
yeah he's so cool you just have to be
cool every day was an event every day it
was somebody showing up oh really
who who were some crazy ones who were
ones that you were like oh [ __ ] and do
you know that cause i hate knowing who's
in the audience i i
refuse to like pay attention to any
anytime there's buzz or chatter
backstage like blah blah blah is here i
it's the last thing i want to know
are you do you care about that no i
definitely want to know because i
remember
uh sting showed up
and i was like oh [ __ ] like stings here
sting showed up and bought a ticket i'm
like can't be sting and we go out on
stage and walking had this thing where
because
he wasn't supposed to but he would talk
to the audience
so every time ever before the play no
during the play oh oh what time he gave
a bit he would look at the audience and
go
no anthony's doing like a finger point
he would connect with them that's crazy
it was hilarious dude
then you have me zoe and we're just
sitting there like
sam's theory about him is that he's
actually like much more normal than
people think
but he liked that there had there was
this perception of him like he was a
weird guy so people it prevented people
from like bugging him all the time he he
felt like it was a way to i think he
plays up the weird thing so people will
leave him alone yeah it makes sense um
yeah
all the press that you're doing is this
for falcon is this for the the winter
soldier well outside the wire okay which
started watching it's great there's a
great scene in it where you say you play
a um
a cyborg would you call him he's like
got a see-through body and uh
and so you've been like manufactured and
you said you say something about
why the army made you look the way you
look you you're referencing your
you're referencing your uh race and you
say
why
and and i thought it was a really
interesting explanation would you just
kind of um paraphrase what that scene
was and how important that is to the
story it's interesting because as
americans we have this whole false
or misconception that
black or white as black americans were
frowned upon and looked upon because of
the history of america we think that's
world history
but as a black man every time i leave
the united states
i see the
interest the attraction the infatuation
with african-american culture
yeah when i go to china when i go to
japan you go to japan there's a whole
culture of people with locks in their
hair and listening to
bob marley and speaking the words of
holly selassie so wow the misconception
of
african-americans being a bastardized
people by the world
is only an american thing basically the
line was there's a reason why the
american government didn't make me a
blonde hair blue-eyed pekka wood from
the midwest
and no matter where you go black is
neutral that's right because it comes
right after a scene where you you defuse
this really tense moment this tense
situation a standoff between
the locals uh in this eastern european
enclave and and and the military um
and another character says how did you
do that and that's that's the context in
which you say it i thought it was really
uh interesting
when we shot hurt locker there were
moments where because you know it was me
jeremy renner and brian garrity in
jordan were you guys in jordan yeah we
were in jordan but the idea of them
being two white dudes
was a whole different thing
because when outside of america when
they think of american culture they
think of white
male
when they think of
black dude
they think a cool hip-hop good time
party [ __ ]
like you know what i mean
like when i was in i was in istanbul
turkey right so i'm in istanbul i'm
walking downtown istanbul by the
hippodrome and this dude selling
chestnuts like he had a chestnut stand
like in like on the streets of new york
and every day i would come out to hotel
and be like yo michael jordan
he mean michael b jordan or michael
jordan
that's the question
he's like michael jordan michael jordan
so about the second day i'm like yo
what's up man he goes hey come here you
you you you black right you american
black right
i'm like yeah he goes hey do you know 50
cents
[Laughter]
that's so funny that was my next
question
[Laughter]
you're making me think
you're making me think of the stephon
marbury uh documentary you see that the
one where it's amazing
from coney island yeah yes yeah
just how embraced he was by chinese
people and yes
the entire film industry the entire
global existence tell us as
african-americans that we have no base
we have no following outside the u.s
but then we leave the u.s
and it's like
[ __ ]
you're it because if you look at all of
culture there is nothing that has
influenced culture
fashion
music
uh television uh film anything more than
african-american culture the number one
influence on on on the globe is hip-hop
also the last dance i mean i'm
remembering those scenes where yeah
basketball jordan you
you helped make basketball a um
like a global thing a global phenomenon
yeah there's a global branding there's a
global being yeah along with being
african-american that no other culture
or society has
and i've experienced that recently and i
find it i find it interesting that the
idea the the outline the the box
of what american is looked at
is
white male
yeah that is interesting and i never
experience i never understood that until
i left the country so going outside the
country now it's more of a relaxed feel
it's more of a
embodiment of peace
than it is a standoffishness
you're also becoming a an ambassador
of an american of american product this
huge american product when you're right
because you're playing a marvel
superhero and
like a captain america at least adjacent
character falcons
looks like he's gonna pick up the mantle
of captain america how prophetic was
that script that series that's coming
out in dealing with race and dealing
with uh what it means like you said what
it means to be an american and how and
and how people are going to perceive
that overseas it's interesting because
the idea of the series is sam wilson
never said yes to accepting the shield
when he was offered the shield by cap he
said this doesn't feel right this is
your shield
right so you know the series is just
the ongoing story
of bucky and i from the blip moving
forward it's interesting dude just
looking at it from the perspective of
just a regular guy like i've realized
how much my life has changed and i
realized you know
as we both understand once you're at a
certain point you can't go back
so now i'm glad i had those experiences
outside the u.s as a regular guy right
could never have those experiences again
yeah now they're not going to see you
now they'll know your name or at least
they'll know your character i'm sure
they they call you by your character
name or michael jordan or michael jordan
right that's right right or on really
bad days charles barkley
uh who do you get mistaken for a lot
when people are like because because i
i've had the thing we've both been in a
similar
whatever that is of fame whatever area
that is where like people know we're
actors but like can't put your celebrity
holding pattern yes yes lying around dtw
waiting to land yeah right exactly yeah
it's uh you know for me i get mistaken
for
so many people dude like i get because
don cheadle's in the mcu i get don
cheeto a lot oh that's right huh
there's a good friend of mine who was on
the wire
when he was on the wire
i was the most famous actor on the wire
who wasn't on the line
oh
i
that's funny i could see and everywhere
he would go
everywhere i would go they'd be like
yo marlow oh that's funny
so it got to the point i started taking
pictures with people ask him
that's funny that's funny
you jamie hector like literally for the
past 15 years because we were both
living in brooklyn at the same time
we're still very good friends
and you know jamie hector all of us you
know it's funny you look at
the actors now who are making their
climb
you know all of us started in the new
york theater scene you know all of us
started in theater school then we all
came in new york together you know
chadwick mahershala jamie all of us all
of us were in
theater so
it's funny like jamie hector dude when
the wire was on tv i couldn't go
anywhere
that's funny i couldn't go anywhere
have you had that mo have you talked to
him about that were you like you
understand all the time i would take
pictures and be like what's my name and
they'll be like jamie i'm like remember
i'm an [ __ ] and i sent him a video
oh you made him an [ __ ] that's funny
that's funny so when we were at
juilliard it was a group of us it was a
group of all the drama students and we
were taking stage combat right
so we would walk by central park
and we would wait for the double-decker
buses to come one dude steve boyer was
like from ohio like five six like a
hundred maybe a hundred pounds little
white dude right uh-huh so whenever the
bus would pull up we'd let steve get
like 15 feet in front of us because we
were taking stage combat we run up to
him and like fake we were kicking
and everybody on the bus would pull out
their cameras and he'd take like stage
combat blood and put it on his face and
he would run away with all of his [ __ ]
and he would go i hate new york
that's amazing
so god knows how many people have that
picture exactly
that's really funny
that's funny
chadwick didn't go to juilliard no he
went to howard howard right right did
you know him
from brooklyn or did you guys get to
know each other on the marvel movies i
met him in uh dc in 1999
1998. oh wow my college girlfriend went
to howard with him
and he was there and i got to meet him
like most actors who went to howard
because of her i knew them
uh so we were cordial friends
and then
you know slowly
his
and my career started to build so we
started being in the same rooms
conversations and spending more time
together
we had known each other since like 98
99. oh wow what a loss what a but
what a great actor i i um
i imagine you guys got to spend a lot of
time together on those movies right i
mean there's a lot of down time and yeah
it was it was it was interesting you
know see because
chadwick did it the right way he went to
school and both of us was from the south
100 invested in our family you know both
of us
we had a very similar background you
know he did it the right way like he
went got his degree
he directed he wrote
like he he's just more
of a a renaissance man
just an actor
you know so when he got his just due
like nobody could say anything bad about
that he paid his dues right
like sterling
herschel same thing like all of us
dory and misik you know omar dorsey all
of us have the same background so we've
been in the same circles in the same
family of friends for
you know 20 years now
life could be a dream
[Music]
would you ever want to direct
a movie anything else like that would
write direct you know i have a i have a
film that i've circled that i'm working
on getting the rights that i would love
to direct that up that i'm going to
direct um but i think it's more so about
just
i'm i'm a firm believer in staying in
your lane
like i feel like a lot of people direct
so that they can put on their resume you
know esthetician
photographer producer it's like a vanity
thing right yeah
you know there's just this one story
because of my nieces
that i want to tell
and you know it's about a young black
girl standing up for what she believes
that's right when i do projects i'm like
if i do this project who am i doing it
for but more so
than with an acting job because there's
so much more
that goes into it there's so much more
time i mean just the end the effort so
much so much more time and that's what a
lot of people don't get like the idea of
directing is that's a lot of time dude
you know i just i don't have the hunger
the passion the desire i didn't get into
this business to be a director there are
certain stories that i think deserve to
be told and if no one else is going to
tell them i want to tell them so you
want to tell this primarily because you
want your i'm sure kids but also your
nieces to be able to see it it's an
important story for them to see
it's a story of encouragement story of
empowerment you know
it's a it's a story of someone standing
of a young lady standing up for what she
believed in when everybody else doubted
her
you know she's literally the muhammad
ali of young ladies like she took
everybody
and
i'll say this because i've just finished
watching
my favorite scene in shawshank
redemption
she's oh i've never seen a spoiler alert
no no no i'm kidding wait wait
don't ruin it
my favorite line in shawshank redemption
is morgan freeman saying andy dufresne
crawled through a mile of [ __ ] and came
out clean on the other side andy
dufresne
anders dufresne crawled through 500
yards
yours i'llness i would never imagine
that's really good that's good that's
tough to do you have the resin like
there's a depth to that voice
that's good
that's really good do you do anyone else
anthony no but i would like to get
morgan freeman i just want to record him
saying my name
yeah my name my name anthony mac that's
it
yeah i just not the same when i do it
[Laughter]
anthony maggie
um that's how my voice sounds compared
to him you must have met him though
right hand oh yeah yeah yeah no we uh we
cool as a fan dude when we did million
dollar baby now this was probably yeah
the most hilarious moment of my career
so i get cast a million dollar baby and
i'm like holy [ __ ] i get to work with
not only
clint eastwood
morgan freeman
and hillary swing like i'm winning yeah
right if i show up on a set
hillary is absolutely amazing just a
beautiful like
just a beautiful actress and clint
eastwood is the coolest white dude to
ever grace the planet because he dirty
harry so
i'm like yo you know
what's up morgan and he goes hey come
here kid i'm like what's up man so we're
talking we're going back and forth
and
i got this uh job offer to star in this
really big
hollywood explosive like
movie this summer like you know like a
tent pole thing a tempo yeah yeah term
for [ __ ] and then i got a job offer
to do this
play
so morgan freeman was in his tent i mean
he was in his trailer so i got a trailer
and i was like yo morgan you know i was
wondering if i could talk to you for a
second so he's like yeah come on in
so i go in and he goes
he's like what's up i'm like look i got
off at this job and it's a lot of money
like it's literally three home depot
buckets of money
and i got off at this play and it's you
know it's off bro it's 500 bucks a week
i was like so i don't understand does it
make sense to continue to do this play
at this point in my career or you know
do i
go after the money and make sure that
i'm recognized for this role he stopped
eating and he looked up at me and he
goes
son i'ma tell you something
do the work
when hollywood wants you they'll come
get you and when they come get you
they'll pay for you ah that is great ooh
i got chills and i was like
holy [ __ ] and then he let out the
stinkiest bird
[Laughter]
i can see that
uh that's i was like
that's 65 years of burping right yeah
you just crushed that right and not
giving a [ __ ] that's that's the way to
punctuate a great piece of advice
you know real homie so deal with my
burps or get the [ __ ] out instead of
doing the movie i turned down the movie
and it was a disaster
and ended up doing the play and it was a
major learning experience a great
opportunity to do this play and um
it just gave me a new perspective on the
business what a smart move um
well what a great impression too but i
cut you off you were going to say that
the character in this thing that you
really want to direct is like the
character it was like andy dufresne in
shawshank oh yeah because she's faced
with every obstacle she's put everything
is put in her path she's always counted
on to lose
but at the end of the day
she achieves something that's really
magical and
that's happiness
you know but like pure happiness real
freedom that can only come from yeah
yeah yeah yeah like when you see a
person that's at peace
and you're like damn that like what's
wrong with that why is that dude so
different
yeah
like
she she achieves that that nirvana
that place of
you know success that we all think you
get from acknowledgement and money but
you only get within yourself right true
success true inner peace that's uh i'm
now i'm thinking about morgan freeman he
strikes me as somebody who has
figured it out he's achieved that
inner peace that
but who knows uh before we have a
lightning round
um and i want to get to it but i want to
ask you about why outside the wire why
what attracted you to this because i
know you produced it as well you know i
grew up in a business wanting to be
wesley snipes
but only in two wong fu thanks for
everything no i want to me you
and chris pratt remaking two wong fu oh
god who every movie like wesley snipes
career to me was the best if you go from
white man can't jump to passenger 50 70
even now the stuff that he's doing now
like if you watch um what was this
trailer directed the movie uh
oh i can't remember the name of the
movie but he i mean his
his acting style now is so effortless
and so cool like he's just really
amazing in his approach to his craft
through his career and i've just you
think the eddie murphy one
the what the eddie murphy one the um the
next coming to america too
no no no no
his performance in dolanite was yeah you
would never expect that murphy i mean uh
uh wesley snipes to do that yeah like
his time his cool his confidence and
that performance i'm like i want to grow
up to be that guy so when i watched this
when i read this movie it it kind of
just screamed at me terminator meets
training day and uh
westley snipes if you look at passenger
57
you look at all these movies he was so
cool
but at the same time
there was a level of sophistication that
he brought to every character that i
just loved you've never seen a movie
a futuristic
like robotic end of the world movie with
two black dudes it's true
you've never seen you can't name it i've
never seen it
you can't name one yeah you know so have
that opportunity as a producer to put
that together with a really interesting
story and ask the question of how much
is enough
in humanity in this day and age with
humanity and our country being where it
is
at what point do you ask yourself the
question when do we go back
to
caring about humanity instead of
financial success
because it used to be our community was
a community we knew our neighbors you
took care of your neighbors but now it's
all about you and your pod in your house
in your thing well when did you start
noticing that i mean you you seem like
you come from
a culture of taking care of you
neighbors and and very communal i'm
picturing a life in new orleans that is
very much looking out for one another
when when did you see it
a rip
i saw it you know when i left new new
york for a reason new york was a very
yeah like a cold
place to me and when i came back here i
expected it to be the new orleans that i
had left 12 years ago
but you know when you move out of the
house you grew up in into your own house
and you have your own car and you cut
your own yard and you blow your own
leaves
you know your neighbors are spiteful
because of it
you know what i mean yeah yeah when your
neighbor across the street yells at you
for
you know sweeping up stuff thing and she
says just because you think you're in
movies you can clean up your yard what
does that mean
yeah i'm in movies i shouldn't be
cleaning up my yard
yeah
suburban yard politics is really
interesting it's really weird dude yeah
and that's my thing that i realize now
is not so much if i own a piece of
property and i live in a neighborhood
and i see a moving truck i go out and
introduce myself to my neighbors huh
now anthony is that a is that a black
and white thing is that a blood is that
a
racial thing that's just like that's a
heaven i have nothing when you look at
it the
economic situation of this country is
very
has taken over for the racial aspect of
this country it goes hand in hand yeah
yeah you know
it's just to a point now
where if you move into it like a gated
community with your gated neighbors your
gated neighbors are like hey you can't
take out your trash until 6 pm
no it's a trash can man the trash man
coming maybe i'm going to bed that folk
yeah you know what i mean yeah well it's
entitlement it's the entitlement that
privilege and money bring yeah that's
what scares me and that's why
for me
it's more so about what can i give what
can i connect to that's why i go to the
same barbershop i've gone to since i was
a kid oh wow i i go and i play golf at
the same golf course i played little
league baseball at when i was 12 years
old yeah wow old dudes talking the same
old [ __ ] that they've been talking for
the past 30 years uh-huh
you know and i go back and they're like
hey move it move it dude buy all of us a
beer uh-huh how do you respond to that
i'm laughing buying beers i mean they're
like yeah
yeah i mean
you're like stanler and waldorf
right
70 year old dude's yelling at me to buy
him a beer i'm gonna buy him a beer yeah
i guess so it was a dumb question
um
what is anthony what is your most
commonly used do you use emojis when you
text you know what i would say i use the
dot dot dot more than anything oh yeah
okay you need to connect a situation of
thought yeah i i text like i talk that's
why i can't be a writer because my
writing comes with train of thought
so you'll be like a david mamet writer
right i would definitely be yes black
yes yeah all right you heard it here
first
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play football you
played football in high school yeah i
played football in high school i was
pretty i was a free safety safety i was
going to say i was going to say safety
baby you come across the middle mac the
knife going to cut you up you were
ronnie lott oh i wish
i was like i was
woodson beautiful version around
you were uh laddish i was like i was
locked jason
you were ronnie light
um
so football god i wish i played football
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life
what would it be or your go-to snack
food you're sent down
snickers
snickers oh snickers ice cream snickers
bars snickers uh smoothies whatever it
says that that's better than caramel
peanut butter knickers
snickers
oh what do you uh
do is it the standard snickers or do you
go like almond snickers no standard what
are you talking about i've never even
sorry because what are you talking about
oh you'd like it maybe that's rich
people [ __ ] i don't know which i can't
afford all that stuff
well you can now
um what's your favorite movie sequel of
all time
i would say gremlins 2.
oh
somebody else said that the new badge
yeah yeah that's so funny gremlins 2 was
because gremlins won a lot of people
don't give credit that was a christmas
movie yes because remember we got gizmo
as a christmas gift yes i feel like we
did some karaoke uh what is your go-to
karaoke song um i have two lou rawls and
barry white um
lou ross um
you're gonna miss my love and uh barry
white practice what you preach
who was your first celebrity crush jamie
lee curtis
ah in halloween no in trading places
okay yes
seeing her in trading places i was like
who is that and why is she not my date
to junior prom
i want to trade places with whoever's
taking her
[Laughter]
yeah jamie lee curtis yeah if you had to
get a tattoo
what would you get and uh and where are
you half tattoos no
i had a tattoo planned
but then i was like why would i do that
i um
i i don't know i would probably get the
top gun logo across my bicep okay
i know why
because top gun is probably
pound for pound
one of the best movies ever made yeah it
is a great movie
it establishes male ego testosterone
driven performances
mildly homosexual it has good music is
everything ah
uh berlin
yellows come on dog
yeah
yeah that was probably soon after
jamie lee cursed that'd be that'd be
tough if you had the option to bring
either one to your prom
that would be hard i would yeah that's
hard that's hard that's the fifth and
meg ryan that was mine that was my i'll
give lady harry met sally i left that
every time i watched that movie i'm like
why is meg ryan not single and dating me
all right
every time
inner space have you seen inner space
interspace was good in a space
in a space
i'll give you that i'll give you that
that's
where i fell in love with her and sam
cook when he's dancing around he that's
quite so cool in the dancing around to
sam cook um
if you uh well what's your favorite
fruit kiwi duh
i love how you said that kiwi
what a stupid question the reason why
they're hard to find dude yeah
it's either a kiwi or a mango that's
there's no way
i have to be a good ripe mango it's it's
it's hard to find a really ripe a good
ripe kiwi that to me is right that's
that's why because yeah they're right
there somebody's sitting there with a a
timer like waiting to eat that food it's
hard yeah yeah it's so delicious
um who would you want to play you in a
biopic
in your biopic that's hard i would want
18 or 19 year old saturday night live
eddie murphy to play me
oh oh oh oh oh that would be that'd be
yes
who's your favorite simpsons character
what's the dude's name uh smithers
oh yeah okay i love smithers ah that's
an excellent answer mr burns
um
well dogs are cats dogs i respect no one
who would answer cats to that question
yeah that's so funny someone just said
who just said cats just to be different
um
there's been a lot of cats lately
no because you have to look at this is
what you have to look at dogs are guys
cats or girls when you come home your
dog is like oh my god i can't believe
you're here i have so much to tell you
i'm so why did you leave me where do i
begin i love you i love you
when you come home your cat's like
are you going to feed me
like
why did i wait this long what are we
doing
like
they're so drastically different and
then you know i know a lot of people
that say cats know their names it's a
lie no matter what do you say to your
cat he's going to answer because he
thinks you have food or you're going to
rub him or you're going to do something
to him your dog he could be a mile away
you say his name he will run through
fire in
i'm just imagining i'm laughing i'm
imagining like all of our like cat
loving audience just being like well i'm
not watching the falcon in the winter
i love my cat knows its name yeah i know
i've heard that a lot where it's like
actually my cat does know and no i've
never witnessed not your pet you are
your cat's pet yeah yeah um
beetles were the rolling stones earth
when the fire
okay okay fair enough
uh seinfeld's on and friends is on what
do you watch oh seinfeld yeah yeah yeah
you have a favorite episode i never got
the friends thing i never did either i
could go like so far white but i felt
like friends was like too white like it
was so white it was like
it was it was it was like translucent
yeah it was it was a lot i was like yo i
have
why don't they have doors on their
cabinets i have no idea what's going on
on this
well i guess i um yeah i never did
either i don't know why i think because
i would have the option i think also i
love seinfeld so much that you know they
were on at the same time um
and golden girls
uh
you buy it you you're at a barbecue
someone makes you a burger what do you
put on it
oh
right in new orleans we call it dressed
you put lettuce tomato pickle mayonnaise
ketchup
mustard and a little bit of hot sauce
what's your go-to you have a go-to hot
sauce
uh crystals i like crystals
crystals okay we have natural color
okay crystals yeah i'd like to try uh i
might be in new orleans buddy in a
couple weeks i might be driving through
um
i will let you know i'll get a dollar
beer and uh i'd love to see you let me
i'm painfully unemployed i'm not doing
anything all right i'm picturing your
four little your puppies
being like dad come on
um
so thank you i took way too much of your
time but man i can't tell you how much i
appreciate it
thanks a lot man i appreciate it good
talking to you
dude
so that happened dude
that happened yeah that's good he's cool
i mean he's like a young morgan freeman
yes sidney poitier
poitier poitier i give a little more
respect yeah
what'd i say earlier uh oh bye bye
speaking of bayou yes yes very
appropriate appropriate story in fact i
after we did the interview he said we
were talking about um wanting to catch
up and
and wanting to hang out in new orleans
there's no better place and
and so he said yeah you know like let me
know when you're you're passing through
because i told him i was going to make
this trip with the van he said it in a
much cooler way of course yeah
let me know when you're passing through
he's like yo hit me up dude um and i did
i said i'm coming in i let him know 24
hours in advance i'm coming through and
he texted me a couple days later he said
you oh you're here like let's hang
i died in there days earlier he's way
too cool to respond right away no what
was i thinking he's not you um but god
who who's cooler than that
uh i i don't know anyone who's cooler
mm-hmm
just we were talking about uh we were
laughing about this earlier that how he
said um
when he was when he played football in
high school and he's like he's time of
playing safety and he's like
yo mac the knife uh you come over the
middle mack the knife will cut cut you
up yeah yeah and we imagined uh i mean
obviously we didn't play football
neither of us uh competitively wanted to
but imagine if we didn't have to build
imagine if we had
there's no way for either of us to say
that line no and sound remotely cool no
you could sound it would sound like try
to say it
you come across the middle yeah
if you come across the middle mac
knife's going to cut you down cut you ah
cut you up
i can't even do the line right
uh i'm going to try it try it
um they asked me if i was a good free
safety um were you a good football
player in high school oh if you come
across the middle mac the knife is going
to cut you up
he's so cool and like that's the thing
about
being able to say a line like that you
can only get away with it if you're
confident about it or if you lean into
the irony of it that's true you know
like if you're making fun of yourself i
guess i could do that when you told me
that this uh interview had happened and
like what how it had happened with it
when he was at a bar yeah i thought for
sure it was unusually unusual but i
really liked it i thought i did too it
was almost like the first
third or whatever it was
was it was like it was a live
podcast with a very unruly audience yeah
yeah an audience that really they didn't
want to be there exactly
yeah but it uh but it was fine it was
totally fine and it was also funny when
people kept coming up to him and saying
hi i think so and
i it it made me admire his focus his uh
that's why he's a good actor he's able
to he really focused on it i i don't
think i'd be able to do that if i were
in that environment and there are people
coming around also i'm sure people were
looking at him and
he he you would never outside the
noise and the sounds of like the street
noise you would never know really uh
based just on his focus his sense of
like
presence and not to dwell too much on
his coolness but i think
that's probably
connected
because he's
grounded he's secure enough to focus on
this kind of thing when there's all
these distractions around i would be too
uncomfortable by that i know he is um
a very impressive person
is he ever i didn't know a lot of this
stuff about his past and about his
his love like how deep his love for
theater was and everything uh he really
has a deep respect and admiration for it
i love that i love that his stories of
growing up and and how he developed his
work ethic
from his father
the roof yeah that's i mean i've been in
this in new orleans in the summer when
in the dead of summer when it's that
like super hot sticky super sticky yeah
i can't imagine it's hard enough like
walking down the street i know let alone
working with you tar that's crazy i know
but again things like that in your
formative years
um allow a person to develop a certain
work ethic strength strength he has a
real
you know i think that's why uh he's so
good at playing a superhero he has a an
innate strength that's hard to say i
understand why they want him in the mcu
yeah yeah i understand why he's welcome
yes yeah that he's been accepted by the
uh i wasn't accepted now he's i i don't
think this is like spoiler right no in
fact i think this is for i think we
should we're helping him to be yeah he's
like the next he really needs us to
promote the next captain america right
isn't isn't that character kind of
taking the mantle i think shield if you
will uh yeah oh nice yeah uh i think so
i think that's the plan but did he i
don't think he was allowed to say that i
don't know i think they want people to
watch this i just were allowed to say it
he didn't he didn't speculate yeah
i think so about who like who's
in my mind
captain america that role is like
rarefied air right like there are very
few people who
are worthy of playing that kind of part
captain america i know you're who better
than this guy i know and and that's why
it was so interesting how he spoke about
uh his how he's perceived overseas and
how
um
black americans are perceived by black
culture black culture is perceived by um
international
culture and i had no idea that clint
eastwood was so revered in the black
community i didn't either i had no idea
no i knew bruce lee yes
he's like every night no no i believe
him yeah sophie is my sophia is my no no
no rose is my boo by boo-boo yeah
something else i can't say no do you
think that his technique oh man having
boys yeah
is real yes you do yeah you heard him i
mean i believe that he believes that oh
i see but do you think that's possible
well i don't know what it is such a
thing how can you say how can you
speculate one way or the other if you
don't know what it is you're right but
the fact that there is any technique at
all that would scientifically
100 of the time lead to
a boy being born instead of a girl it
can't be on me to me that does not sound
possible
he's very confident and he's very
smart and uh sure of himself so
it's hard not to believe him it's one of
those sounds absurd it does doesn't it
but but that but his confidence is what
made it so compelling and his confidence
coupled with
the fact that it does sound absurd he's
also a really good actor i know but like
why would he
act that way if there was such a
technique don't you think people would
know about it by now maybe people do
some people don't you think you would
have heard about it before yeah but i i
also haven't tried to have kids before i
know but you you know people who have
kids you would have heard about it
you're a person who exists in society
that type of
information
would not be a secret i don't believe it
it's one of those things that i mean
he's so he's he sold it well me too that
was funny when he was like you don't
have kids what's wrong you don't
kids but like
said that you like
it's funny because i know that you like
kids probably more than any person i
know
so it's like an absurd thing to say to
you i know i know and he's like what
have you been doing and then how about
when he was like well i was old when i
get that thirty years ago oh my god i
know
i didn't and i also didn't really
understand
fully why he wanted all boys no when he
did he was saying things like i just
think if i had a girl i'd be like two
too good
i'd be like playing dress-up with her
and like getting tall stuff that sounds
great
i know but then finally he was like oh i
had all these older sisters and an aunt
and a mom and they were all like kind of
like yeah
yeah it's like oh there's your answer
right right but again what about his
wife i mean she'd probably have that
experience i'm sure she
of course she wasn't on the show
she must have known that he was doing
the technique
but he said it wasn't a position thing
no but he didn't say it wasn't a
physical he said it also wasn't a
dietary thing so it's not about what you
eat what else is there um
not a position thing not a dietary thing
maybe uh a timing thing like a time when
you do oh maybe that's true okay that
must be what it is a position thing or
not a diana what else is there
but if you guys know about this oh yeah
uh please yeah please by all means i'm
i'm very curious now uh hey let's read a
little okay all right what do you think
that christopher walken story tremendous
yeah right great yeah but you know what
i want to end the matt damon story i
know right he has to write tells great
story he does he's great it was a really
good episode
yeah yeah good i well that's why i was
like um i asked him about directing
because i feel like he he seems so in
charge and he's such a good storyteller
that i just thought like god what a
natural fit that seems he seems like a a
natural leader yeah and a good story he
could definitely do it no and whether he
was like i don't want to get into this
business exactly he's like a true actor
um okay here's a letter from
nita this is from nita brazowski nita
true crime versus life is short hi
justin my true passion since i was a kid
after discovering my dad's true crime
encyclopedia is i love all things murder
well
but once in a while i need a break and
your podcast is the perfect mix my
favorite part is the end when you and
your brother christian discuss how the
interview went and read a letter from a
podcast listener hey what we're doing
right now we're doing now yeah this is a
good murder break yeah it is
so i thought i'd write you some would
you rather questions to ponder over
thank you nita
and there's no way it'd be nida would it
it's n-i-t-a
like i think like lita ford is l-i-t-a
you're right nina it'd have to be anita
nita i think it's nita you say nita i
say naida needa night okay here we go
back tonight anita
it's it's neither neither or naida
okay okay sorry
okay okay would you rather
marry a woman who has the looks
personality intelligence and humor that
is perfect for you but has the absolute
worst incurable halitosis oh great or my
stomach just turned when you said the
word hell there's something about that
word palatine is that like you
immediately know what that smells like
it's so like clinical yeah yeah oh god
or
mary is that such a fear of mine that i
have that that i know you are very
paranoid i am breath i am okay or
marry a woman you know what i've been
noticing like sometimes now with the
mask when you're wearing the mask you
can smell your own mouth yeah i don't
know i think that the other day wait a
minute you both have to notice
while wearing a mask to prevent covet
spread
in fact sometimes i notice your breath
your your bur you uh like i'll walk into
one of your burbs i did i just walked
into one that was smelled delicious you
had just popped this is not an ad you
popped a mango a dry mango from uh our
new sponsor i'm so excited about them
but we won't talk about that yeah but
we're excited about it
okay they're the best okay
back to nita nida
okay so that's a great first one
i'll do it again because it's been five
minutes since i said it marry a woman
who has the looks personality
intelligence humor that is perfect for
you but has the absolute worst incurable
halitosis or
marry a woman who has the looks and
intelligence you desire but is someone
that
bores you about 75 percent of the time
huh
so the second one is looks and
intelligence but not humor and
personality and all that
right which is why it's boring to you
75 of the time but i'm saying the second
person the position of the person is
smart and attractive yeah
but they're not funny and personable and
all that which is why they bore you yeah
but but to be bored i can understand
like not being like interested interest
there's a different you're right there's
a difference between bored yeah and like
neutral yeah right to be bored is that i
don't i think i'd should choose the
halitos let's but let's say i get used
to the the way
uh nita
was talking about board was was more
neutral let's say it was more like just
not fun or super exciting it was just
kind of like that so you so you need a
little clarity
uh that's how i'm imagining it so 25 of
the time you have thoughtful discussions
or yeah being romantic because you're so
attracted to her but 75 of the time
you're kind of on your own and you're
just not connecting with with this
person yes that's how i'm imagining yeah
okay instead of being bored i mean to be
bored it's like there's there's
something more active about being poor
exactly yeah let's say the let's say
okay all right um in that case if it's
the former rather than the ladder
um i would hmm i would probably
choose the the uh non-halitosis one the
the
cause because you know at a certain
point you should be on your own yeah
yeah but here's the problem sorry to
push back uh it's it's if you're
attracted to her
and you think and she's intelligent so
you could have
good like smart conversations
but she's not funny or personable and
all that i would argue that 25 of the
time even when it's like not boring
that's just like it's superficial not
just superficial but like you you might
be exercising your brain in an in a you
know an active way but it doesn't sound
fun because for me
intelligence and humor and person those
are all separate things
like humor and intelligence are
connected it's true so without the humor
i don't care what percentage it is you
need that and i so i would i would
deal with the hell me too me too i would
figure out a way i would like always
have
something in my no you know i would do
something like something in your nose
like uh nose plugs or something yeah
she'd feel so self-conscious or i would
just learn to always breathe through my
mouth
oh i just never breathe it i think you
would get just get used to it and it
would become
i think if she were that great and she
had all those things i'm thinking of
like and somebody that makes you laugh
and you all of those things you would
you want to hold on to that you'd want
to hold on to that and i think you'd
start uh
associating even the bad breath with
something i would imagine
yeah you get used to it yeah i agree and
also think about like the
it's like the way if i force myself if
if like some stinky cheese had all those
other attributes if some stinky cheese
made me laugh and all those things i
people eat that stuff you would probably
start to like that smell not bad but
cheese is different
you have to make it not to you
but there's plenty of people who enjoy
that type of cheat stinky cheese but
who enjoys halitosis well think about it
it's not it's not just an acquired taste
kind of thing it's like
objectively
uh repugnant okay well let me present
this to you
you haven't you had when you've had bad
breath we were just talking about
smelling it in the mask i've never had
halitosis halitosis i
smell specific i've made bad odors i
know but that's different than halitosis
i know but my point is like i don't mind
my bad odor that's a totally different
thing
really yeah that's your own brand what
is it who like i'm trying to think of
halitosis now if i've ever i'm thinking
of someone in particular not someone i
dated but no i know i think i know uh
someone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right is it is that the end of the
letter no no there's another that's a
great would you rather it is i'm gonna
be thinking about that for a while yes
okay and there's another one exciting
okay
would you rather have a forehead have a
forehead that is 12 inches tall
or have a chin that is 12 inches long
a 12 head
instead of a forehead yes
um wait 12 chin or forehead
12 head
oh i would rather have the 12 inch chin
well i think about a 12-inch chain
12-inch chin because you look like a
cartoon the joker either way
you would look very different right but
and either way you could do something
about it if you had a inch forehead you
could wear a big hat and you could do
more about the chin chin you can tuck it
under your shirt oh i thought you're
going to say just like cosmetic like
surgically no forget surgery no you
you're
you can't get rid of these the
hypothetical is what would you rather
live with because you couldn't get rid
of a 12-inch forehead
in this hypothetical you can't get rid
of either what do you think jay leno's
chin was like i was thinking about jay
leno five inches uh
maybe six okay imagine that twice as
long as janet
it's a lot but i think also a forehead
i've always been a little insecure about
my chin and i've always wanted like a
stronger right jawline because we don't
come from
strong jawline people that's true i'm
more i'm more insecure about chin and
bottom of my face than the top of my
face yes so if i had to enhance one of
them i probably would pick the bottom of
my hand okay yeah i you know both want a
bigger chin for it uh that's true okay
thanks anita those are great um
now i'm thinking about like
somebody who's has just like a face that
they don't worry about you know i'm tom
brady
anthony matthew mackey yes okay
um so speaking of anthony mackie thank
you oh yeah
uh doing the show and being my dude so
cool yeah and so cool uh being
such a open
good storyteller yeah and um really
important stuff that he said i like i'm
really
as fun as it was there was also uh you
know i was talking about some really
important [ __ ] that like i really opened
my eyes to some stuff that uh
i i you know would not have occurred to
me and i loved what he had to say about
chadwick and and those great actors uh
he's just such an important actor and
person yeah he's great so um so thank
you to him and thank you to nita and
um if you guys would like to write into
the show our email address is life is
short at wondry.com
uh we'll talk to you next week
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by and produced by
you christian long megan monaco senior
producer is michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez on
this one there's an executive producer
whose parents named him marshall louis
all of this is done under the banner of
uh a company that rhymes with uh nundary
wondering
they were going to take us right wasn't
that it what they were going to take his
financial aid away they threatened him
it's a long time ago
yeah i've seen it a couple times it's a
good movie
but it's funny that you would describe
scented woman as a it's a movie about a
kid who drives a block i mean like a
blind man who needs
a driver i mean i guess that's how it
starts yeah but no this is the scene in
which he wants to be at the wheel yeah
oh that's right and he drives i mean he
wants to feel what it's like to drive
yeah and and so we have the young guy
telling him how where to turn that's
right
you know
in real life
it would have been a terrible action
i'm sure
you